Her low freak bitches most of the time it's bad technique.
Most of the times with the lead lag and they don't step open to right foot,
so the angle cannot go like a 90 degree angle into the muscle and it kick
straight up.
It'd be,
she goes,
look,
I've everybody who gets kicked to the pills,
I guarantee you the leg that they're standing on the toes are pointing forward.
If they will pointed the site,
it will be okay.
Well with check,
I believe it was knees and the clinch.
Oh it was,
I think it was just
a tight box or shooting on it.
I never need anybody and bill,
I did once actually,
but that was on purpose.
I guess they rose.
I if I could fight video from that,
that is the best deal.
So I fight where they,
Rosie,
you heard about that right?
The taller guy from whole,
a total psychopath they say and it does always illegal thing.
So we're fighting him and I'm the first ride.
I beat the crap out of him in a second ride would come out and be a clinching
and he bites in my ear and I'm shouting,
let go,
let go.
And then you see my knee going all the way back and then I need him as he comes
loose from the ground.
That's how I knew him in the bills.
He goes down and I wanted to attack him on the ground,
but they pulled me off.
And then,
uh,
core Hybris was in my corner.
Now he brought all his friends was he had hell's angels with him and,
and I had all my bosses friends with me and they all started fighting.
They throw us,
they threw a chair into the ring.
It bounced off core hammers says beck at LEDs behind me.
If you see the video,
man,
it lags behind me.
I looked behind me,
I see the chair,
I sit in the chair while I watch.
And that later they cleared everybody.
Everybody's throwing down because the referee took,
he says,
why did you do it?
I said,
look at my ear.
And it was a hole straight through my air.
He bitched straight through my ear,
a in there and then he grabbed a microphone and he announced to everybody,
you know,
Whoa,
he's got a hole in his ear.
He bit his ear.
That's why he did it.
And then everybody calm down.
Oh Wow.
And did you continue to fight?
No,
no,
no.
That was it.
It was a hard knee.
And the idea of where we live twice as long as our ancestors did a century ago,
you know?
Yeah,
that's true.
But really no one's living above 120 just more and more people are pushing up to
the upper ceiling because of public health and just general stuff we do that
makes us healthier.
But in terms of longevity and aging,
you can't stop it.
All she could do is kind of hopefully slow it down a little bit and,
and you want to have a higher quality of life the further up you go as opposed
to lying in bed with tubes for the last 10 years of your life or something like
that.
So that was,
that's where the future research is.
Where the breakthroughs will come.
Not,
not radical life extension lists that I've also written about.
You know,
we're going to have 500 years,
the Schermer don't you want to live 500 years?
Like look,
just get me to 90 without Alzheimer's and cancer.
Okay,
let's just start one decade at a time.
It just easy,
you know,
because you know the problems are really complex.
I think the quality of life thing that you mentioned is one of the most
important things.
Like we have this phrase that I've said many times,
but I'm going to say,
cause it fits right here.
We all love to sleep,
but everyone's afraid to die.
We love to shut off.
We'd love to shut off at night.
Everybody loves it and we look forward to it.
But that one big shutoff off when you're not coming back is just too fucked up.
It's just too much.
Well,
it's inevitable.
This is my,
in my next book I have a chapter called,
uh,
afterlife for atheists.
So these are not just the radical life extension is,
but the p the mine loaders.
And so,
you know,
you're going to scan your connectome,
put it in a computer,
and then you know,
you'll wake up in the computer like Johnny Depp in that sentence mood.
Here's the problem.
When you go to sleep,
then you wake up tomorrow,
maybe you're groggy for a few minutes,
but you're,
you're,
you're back.
You still feel like you,
there's a continuity between today and tomorrow or you get general anesthesia
surgery.
You wake up groggy or for a little bit longer,
but the continuity comes back.
It's still you.
So the question is,
is if you're,
you die and we have a scan of your connectome and we put it in a computer and
turn it on,
are you going to wake up in the computer like you did from sleep?
And I don't think so.
I think it would just be a copy of your,
if this could ever be done,
which is very unlikely because it's super hard problem.
But let's just say it could.
Um,
I,
I think there's a break in continuity from death.
You're dead.
That's it.
And this thing we have is a copy of you.
It would be like if we cloned your body and then you die and then we reconstruct
the body and there you are.
That's not you.
Not first person through the eyes.
Me,
it's just a copy of me.
I've always had this rose colored view of us and I acknowledged that it's a
myth,
but I always look at the myth of America as I call it,
the 1950s high school textbook view of America.
That to me is what I want to move towards.
So when they talk about creating a more perfect union,
that to me is the goal and anything that conflicts with that self image to me is
the problem.
So when you see sometimes how we really operate anything Dick Cheney does,
and I don't use the word evil,
so I'll use the word nefarious Dick Cheney is to me,
when you say,
what do you want to avoid in this country?
I want to avoid where Dick Cheney wants us to go because nothing conflicts with
my 1950s mythological American textbook idea than what Cheney wants us to be.
And when you look at some of the things we'd done,
some of the things based on that 1947 1948 America,
which we thought could we have to do everything to stop global communism?
They're going to take over the country.
Why don't you look at some of the things we did and you realize some of what
we're dealing with today is blow back.
You don't know how to undo that.
I mean,
you almost think it's like permanent damage.
Look at the way some in the Middle East see us.
I mean,
uh,
I'll,
I'll talk to people like,
I remember talking to Sam Harris about this and he was talking about what you
have to see things this certain way.
And I said yes,
but that's not going to help you solve the problem.
How do you solve the problem if we've already,
if we've already soiled our beds so much that you don't know how to fix that,
you don't know how to go and say,
listen,
we're sorry about this.
Can we start from scratch?
You can't do that in foreign affairs.
Just like you can't do it with the mainframe computer.
That is the government,
you know?
I can't figure out how to,
how to reverse course to a point where we can once again fix stuff.
Right?
It's,
it's too damaged.
I think it just has to dry out slowly but surely.
Look,
all the wounds of the past have to heal up and dry out and it just takes time.
Deal generation.
Do you mean rate?
We've already made enough people mad at us so that thereafter us,
well now we have to go protect ourselves by going and getting them.
So we perpetuate the cycle.
Like I can't figure out how to jump off the merry go round.
Do you know what I mean?
I don't think it moves that way.
I think we're trying to make a battleship move like a race car and I just think
it takes a long time to shift course and when we're looking at these people that
are in the Middle East that are opposing the u s right now and angry and want
attack the US right now,
you're most likely never going to get to them.
You might get to their grandchildren.
And I think that might be the only way.
Things slowly but surely settled down.
And that's the argument for the NSA and the CIA to continue to monitor things
that are really kind of ridiculous and invasive level because there's so many
people out there that hate us or hate the government,
hate the military and hate what's happened to them.
And so many martyrs are created every time a drone strike was going to go,
how do you,
how do you get that next generation to not hate us when we're busy killing their
parents because their parents want to kill us?
That's the cycle and I can't figure out how to break the cycle.
How do you protect ourselves from their anti American parents in a way that
doesn't turn them against us too?
Does that make sense?
Okay.